the habit of punishing people for their  opinions  is a way of disabling  uh our most powerful  means of of implementing rationality in  the world  pretty much our only one given that  humans as rational as they are really do  have  biases and flaws  and that is you try out a hypothesis you  see if it withstands scrutiny criticism  evaluation if you're not allowed to  broach a hypothesis in the first place  then there are possible solutions that  you  could never discover because it's  even considering it might be  criminalized so cancel culture  abrogations of  academic freedom and free speech are  irrational because they disable  mechanisms of rationality